trappes ville de 32 1714 habitants où
cinq candidats se font face pour les
élections municipales président de la
pépinière d'entreprises promo paul
lotman d'astro est candidat pour la
deuxième fois au scrutin dans la ville
après 2014
l'élu d'opposition également conseiller
régional fait équipe avec mustapha
larbaoui l'ancien président du club de
football local sa liste est soutenu par
la droite et le centre départemental
aujourd'hui on a construit un grand
rassemblement autour d'un projet est
alors que nous avons identifié les dix
priorités essentielles qui sont celles
des habitants qui sont celles que nous
défendons depuis 2014
il ya des choses utiles qui ont été
faites à trappes ces vingt dernières
années mais ce qui n'a pas été fait en
20 ans ne le sera pas dans les
prochaines années par les mêmes
personnes
il faut donc qu'on aille sur les sujets
qui n'ont pas encore été traités c'est
une première candidature pour lui aux
municipales à trappes
patrick planque était déjà en lice il ya
trois ans sur le territoire comme
candidat suppléant aux dernières
législatives
comme toutes les listes lutte ouvrière
il souhaite organiser la lutte des
travailleurs au niveau de la commune
c'est une ville ouvrière avec une longue
histoire de lutte
quand même et quand on parle aujourd'hui
de recréer un parti à parti d'une
travailleurs en parti ouvrier qui
organiserait les choses dans les
quartiers qui organiserait les choses
dans la ville est bien dans les plus
anciens
il ya une petite étoile il est le maire
de trappes depuis 2001 guy malandain est
en lice pour un quatrième mandat dans la
ville une candidature divers gauche
soutenu par la république en marche le
parti socialiste et le parti radical de
gauche
l'élu souhaite rester à la tête du
conseil municipal pour voir aboutir les
projets lancés comme l'enfouissement de
la nationale 10 il ya besoin de
continuer au plan humain social éducatif
urbanistique etc
il ya besoin de continuer de poursuivre
la politique qui a été menée jusqu'ici
pour pour terminer alors vu terminer
n'avait pas dire qu'il faudra rien faire
il ya encore des choses qui me tiennent
à coeur
cette campagne est son premier
engagement politique bakou keita et la
tête de liste de citoyens en actions
candidature portée avec son binôme
youssef bouchikhi est derrière eux un
collectif d'habitants qui souhaite que
les trappistes se réapproprient leur
ville en favorisant notamment la
démocratie locale
l avis des trappes est gérée par des
gens qui sont pas issus trappe déjà et
qui te connaissent pas nos problèmes on
a beaucoup de difficulté à trappes
niveau logement social jeunesse et
caetera et nous on veut mettre le point
sur sa et vraiment travaillé la mêlée
raison de tout ça quoi enfin l'adjoint
au maire ali rabe est également candidat
face au maire sortant sa liste est
soutenu par génération europe ecologie
les verts et le parti communiste
l'élu peut compter aussi sur l'appui de
benoît hamon côté éducation c'est le
retour à la semaine de quatre jours
qu'il souhaite pour la rentrée 2020 donc
on a organisé un référendum pendant
trois semaines nous sommes allés au
contact des habitants dans les marchés
chez l'habitant dans les gares dans les
écoles également et on a recueilli plus
de mille votants ce qui est vraiment
très impressionnant et qui montre que
les trappistes ont envie de donner leur
avis à près de 80% les trappistes ont
décidé de revenir à la semaine de quatre
jours